今日は弾み雪をですネットで話題になってたんですけどもこちらのパンご存知でしょう
か
ファミリーマートから出ておりますパンでロシアンルーレット1個だけはささみ入りの
パンです遊び方としてはもうハロウィン用パンなんでなんかパーティーとかで1人1個
ずつコーツ切って食べると誰が1人が鋏ないよじゃあみたいな感じでございますいやー
これけっこう
すごいと思うんですよ2コンビニ行ってあんまり遊ばないイメージがあると思うんです
よ
たまにひねり技でちょっと不思議なあちを出したりすると思うんですけども完全にクソ
日じゃないですかを完全に朝食要素で売ってるんで次暴挙にでたなぁいい意味でですよ
e 3でボーイズに出たなと思いましてあげてみましょう
[音楽]
でから待って本当にでかいんだけどこんなでかいことあるパーティーですからね大きく
ていいと思うんですけどねなんかなんと369円でございました
そもそもどれくらいのおばさんで料が入ってるかもわからない他のパンは何味かも
ちょっとよくわからない肉入ってねえけど声ですね水で私を守ったことがあるんですよ
なくてないんですけど民のパンってコーナーが構造とか製造しているわけだと思うんだ
したコーナーが9とかできるっ
動作の中でランダムに1個だけはサイパンにすることって工場の知ってるぞできるの
かっていうれる
僕ちょっとできないと思うんすよ構造でつくるもらって同じ動作を繰り返してものなん
でしょそんな同じ動作を繰り返す中でこのランダムの1個だけワサビ味のパンを入れる
事って僕できないと思うんですよそれで工場長玩具にして
右下 here 真ん中左あ違う右上みたいな感じでなんか命令しやってると非効率で
生産性に乏しいと
んですよ商品というのは売ってなんぼですから捧げにその非効率なことをしてないと
思うんで僕の予想だと工場でお体で例えばはかんですけど右下だけで大和刷版みたいな
確定演出されてんじゃないかなと僕を持って今回は遊びパーをなる誰か買ってきました
僕の予想があっていればですよ構造でそんなにランダムに1個だけはサイパンにする
みたいな女
た臭いとおさせず400パーセントの確率同じ場所でばサイパンから可能性が見慣れ
ない僕は持ったのでエレベーターさんのロシアンルーレット盤を準備しましたハード
ケースが正しければ全部度でも同じパターンで同じばサイパンが発動してしまうと思い
ましたさあすってよ書込
プレゼントいたします
[音楽]
うん
はい合計12個のロシアンルーレットパンを手に入れました
1個あたりに9個付いてるんで中にかける究極初このロシアンルーレットパン置いて
ありますでは早速ばサイファーの入っている場所の確率を出していきましょう
12個まではさせるに完璧とは言わないんですけども程よい統計が取れるのではないか
なと思いますでは冷めていきましたよねまず俺一番怖いのがでバソリーパーの威力よ
これで
[音楽]
ブーバーンがちょこちょこちゃっアティ
一個でお腹いっぱいいやこれ俺その勝負だなあの女がいっぱいになったら検証し常に
なりますんで誰か早くわさび版わけないとどんどんはんちゃまっていくんだよって絶対
ばそんなんだと思うんだよな
じゃあ見に行きます
んグリーンぱーるーぱんなやっぱこういうのって真ん中なんですかね
ちょっと真ん中行ってみますあ食べます
んんん
1 ani
あさあ
ああーっでも美味しいで2つとに行かないですけど風がコミュニストは程よい辛さです
そんな絶望的に何か子を陥れるカーかがないですよ
美味しいはためのはずでしたなるほどやはり真ん中から僕の理論があっているとこれ
0万な所わさびのパンチでございますね
ただバカなんですけどさらにパターン準備せて真ん中左上真ん中左上みたいな
夢の意地でくる可能性になってしまいますまあこの後くっぺくとどんどん上がっていく
と思います次が車
真ん中さっきわさびだったんでもどんどんいただきますいただきますねっ
わさびじゃないってことはもうこの時点ではんだが100%の可能性はなくなりました
ねやはり読めなくなってきたなぁただちょっと傾向と対策を練るためでもありをずっと
進めていきましょういやこれ皆さんはサビパンの場所わかってたらマジあずですからね
例えばあの女でも害するパーティーとかそれでしょ
その中でやっぱり罰ゲームってね当たった奴が勝ちなんすよ罰ゲーム当たった方が絶対
おいしいね女の子とか
ハロウィンパーティするときねもうは裁判の場所が事前に分かっていればそこを狙って
くればもうなーんだってもそんなカーってあると思うんだよぜひ場所を覚えていって
くださいドイツここの朝一番の場所だけあってますしたいきますお家なんじゃげます
ん
クリームパン底だぜ腹が膨れてきた全部口と約1000キロカロリーですねぇー
左下いきます
チョコパンですねうーんまだた右でいきますいただきます
[音楽]
まあ違ったハイパーってどんな触れちゃう1個全部食べちゃうよ
3個目で早くもつまづくと渡瀬からロシュのルーレットパン俺の腹はもう腹並ぶぐらい
ここで当てないと次はないです
植木ナース止めはさすがにこれではてってくる姉とフェ
使いましたやばい1個全部食べちゃうよやばいやばい本当にやばい
まずよ右下
voodoo
書庫番でしたただこれ木鶏を気づいたんですけど次のは最初だけなんですよ食べていく
ことによっては錆びたんだ場所がどんどん確定されてくるんで抵抗が見えれば対策もし
やすい体操だけの辛抱ですがんばります diggy
ペアじゃあばかりバーンねぇ罰ゲームじゃねーよこれ
感動して美味しく感じます辛いけど今行ったところは真ん中1回右1回斜め上
右上左下とか呪いの感じたしてまず最優先で今真ん中と右やすく言えばちょっと当たる
可能性があるということなんで次から絞っていきますいいい
まんだが正しい制限なくなってきたわいただきました
paddy 見て見ぬフリパンなぁああ
あーん21ます持ってください
あっ細いまだ4ダメバーガー
voodoo
カラーいやでもすごい強い迷っ作って真ん中に会
右側に1回これ2パターンの可能性出てきましたよこれ真ん中と右で食ってるます
できるんだねあそねちょっとね僕の持論なんですけど形から推測できるかもしれないん
だよな多分これとかね真ん中だと思う真ん中できますいただきます
[音楽]
ブルーム版ですねなんとこれは右かな右食べますやそれでもと右だったらもうほぼ確定
だよという
折っちまったクリームパンダ出番なかったみぎの可能性はないもらうと次はどこだ
上田上田そういった船を得るの要素と上な気がすんだよ上食べてみます
もうあんたぁああ掘ったようでず梅田犯されてるよだとにごくったらもう約200
カロリーですけどね
俺は今日何時にいつ何も食べずにしてみます有難う御座いました星高梨たいきますと
思います
[音楽]
a by ジャガー左酷いです今同梱斜めの右上と右下左下左上とかなかったんで
いただきます
o 私はなぜくーっなんだか
一発パティエ本当にぽつっ
いただきますうん
グリー部ゲーちょっとわからん
ん
うーん確定で左です斜めゾーンには今のところなかったんでこの統計によると多分ない
と思います
これ絶対技類
もうをがフォア出かけちゃってカーラーでも24個食べるんだけどやばい一時女性ちん
男性の必要摂取量を超えてしまっている
死ぬこの先斜めが出た時点で安全にラサムってことが証明されますがこのまま真ん中右
が左がぜ続けるともう
パターンとされてるだということになりますアンカー一発だ0
ん
左
ずっと言えですうん
となるとこれたらした確定だなぁ
山ている
俺の腹
もう限界や猫遺族と原壊れてまあでも次のいってればサビ版を与えてしまうと確定的な
情報が不足しているためこの企業まだ続けなければいけない必要がある
いやここでばサビパン以外はてるとこの器具は遊び版は何ダメでしたちゃんちゃんで
終わってしまう
ここが出るしかない俺の花のためにも待てるアピロス取り組んだ
もうすぐっ
んだたぶん普通のば普通パーククリームは序盤クリバージョン[ __ ]にも終えが増え
バックば塗ってる
こうじゃじゃあ
まなびばブラッ
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ
すいませんもう限界ですね約30個を食べてしまいました山盛り3000業界じゃねえ
3000kcal 食っとるやんけ
それでちょっとこれ以上のカロリー摂取は実装だし僕も食べれないんでここで1回
ストップさせていただきます7個食べた結果
真ん中がに右日に左がにしたが1今のところ斜めゾーンにばから4番入ってません
ただちょっと花が終わればもったいないんでどこには遊び場もある方にちょっと見て
いきましょう
今じゃされ方でくださいありがとうございます
ブーンパパ
あっ方々母ちゃーん
ああああああ
パール pearl moon うわぁ1よじゃあよっちゃうっ
[音楽]
ん
うんよりね獣肉をやってみたチェックが出ました
このキックからを取ることは斜めはまずないと思ってくださいわからないでしょとし
あるかもしれないけどこの統計上で結果
斜めには遊び場があるとかありませんでした結果組んで決め飯より
ですね右に入ってる可能性が高いですかわかんないも2パターンだけならここ
真ん中にいるか右に入れるかで
ずーっと回転させればいいんじゃよ確かにそうだよね
構造でパンのおじさんが入れるときにはたちと回転して入っていけるのか
まつげまたれた人はぜひ十字を狙ってみてはいかがでしょうか
どうでした